to find the prime factors of a 2048-bit
number it would take a classical
computer millions of years a quantum
computer could do it in just minutes and
that is because a quantum computer is
built on qubits these devices which take
advantage of quantum superposition to
reduce the number of steps required to
complete the computation but how do you
actually make a qubit in practice and
how do you read and write information on
it I met up with researchers who are
using the outermost electron in a
phosphorus atom as a qubit this single
phosphorus atom is embedded in a silicon
crystal right next to a tiny transistor
now the electron has a magnetic dipole
called its spin and it has two
orientations up or down which are like
the classical 1 & 0 now to differentiate
the energy state of the electron when
it's in spin up and spin down you need
to apply a strong magnetic field and to
do that we use a superconducting magnet
so superconducting magnet is a large
solenoid is a coil of superconducting
wire that sits inside of that vessel as
full of liquid helium so now the
electron will line up with its spin
pointing down that's its lowest energy
state and it would take some energy to
put it into the spin up state but
actually not that much energy and if it
were at room temperature the electron
would have so much thermal energy that
it would be bouncing around from spin up
to spin down and back and so you need to
cool down the whole apparatus to only a
few hundredths of a degree above
absolute zero that way you know that the
electron will definitely be spin down
there is not enough thermal energy in
the surroundings to flip it the other
way now if you want to write information
onto the qubit you can put the electron
into the spin up state by hitting it
with a pulse of microwaves but that
pulse needs to be a very specific
frequency and that frequency depends on
the magnetic field that the electron is
sitting in so what you see here is the
frequency that is being produced by this
microwave source and it's 45.0 21
gigahertz which in the magnetic field
that we are applying now is the
resonance frequency of the electric so
the electron is a little bit like a
radio
they can only tune into one station and
when that station is broadcasting the
electron gets all excited and turns to
the spin up state but you can stop at
any point so if you just make it mutate
and stop your pulse at some specific
point what you've created is a special
quantum superposition of the spin-up and
spin-down states with a specific phase
between the two super positions and how
do you read out the information will you
use the transistor that this phosphorus
atom is embedded next to the spin down
has the lower energy and the spin up as
the higher energy now in this transistor
there is in fact a little puddle of
electrons this puddle of electrons is
filled up up to a certain energy so this
vertical axis here is energy and here we
were all these electrons that line up in
energy just like the electrons on the
shells of an atom so now if the electron
is pointing up it can jump into the
transistor but because it has more
energy than all the others it leaves
behind the bare nuclear charge of the
phosphorous right the phosphorous one
more positive charge in the nucleus as
compared to silicon but normally it's
neutralized by the extra electron so the
two things cancel out but if you take
the electron away then the phosphorous
has a positive charge
so it says if you have a positive
voltage a more positive voltage applied
to this game it doesn't come from the
gate it comes from the atom but it's the
same it's just a positive voltage it's
like the transistor has been switched
more on and so you see a pulse of
current and that indicates that the
electron was in the spin up State in
this measurement phase if you find one
of these spikes of current it's because
you had an electron spin up so you can
play catching a spin up or spin down
electrum you see there was no current
here that was a spin down alike and try
again again a spin down elector
in effect now these researchers have
actually gone further using the nucleus
of the phosphorus atom as a qubit like
an electron the nucleus has a spin
although it's 2,000 times weaker than
the spin of the electron but you can
still write to it the same way using
electromagnetic radiation only it needs
to be a longer wavelength and a longer
pulse in order to get the spin to flip
because it's so small so weakly magnetic
and so perfectly isolated from the rest
of the world
it's a qubit that lives for a very long
time but how do you read out the spin of
the nucleus well you use the electron
remember that the electrons frequency
that it will respond to depends on the
magnetic field that it's sitting in so
that magnetic field is the external
magnetic field that is produced by the
superconducting magnet but there is also
an internal magnetic field coming from
the nucleus but that internal magnetic
field can have two directions right the
nucleus can be pointing up or down
itself so what it means is that there
are two frequencies at which the
electron can respond depending on the
direction of the nucleus so the nucleus
actually acts as a little selector it
tells the electron basically which radio
station it can listen to so what you're
looking at now is an experiment where we
actually flip the nucleus every five
seconds so for five seconds you will see
that the electron always responds
because the nucleus is always in the
right direction to make the electron
respond to the frequency by applying to
the electron and then for the other five
seconds the electron will not respond
because we have flipped the nucleus the
other way so now what you see in this
period of time the nucleus has been
flipped down yeah
and now after five seconds it will flip
up the same trend starts responding yeah
so you are watching on the oscilloscope
screen in real time the measurement of
the direction of a single nucleus and
our ability to flip it at will every
five seconds sing
all nucleus now because all of this
depends so sensitively on magnetic
fields you need to make sure to
eliminate all spin from the silicon
crystal but unfortunately natural
silicon contains about 5% the isotope
silicon 29 and that does have a spin but
in fact the beauty of silicon is that it
has this isotope called silicon 28 that
has no nuclear spin the nuclear spin is
zero so it's a completely non-magnetic
atom but where are you going to find a
pure crystal of silicon 28 oh wait these
isotopically purified silicon 28
crystals are being produced anyway for a
purpose completely different from
quantum computing they're being produced
to redefine the kilogram through the
Avogadro project so the offcuts from
that silicon sphere are actually being
used as the home for qubits that I think
is incredible there is no waste in this
science hey there this episode of
veritasium was supported by audible.com
a leading provider of audiobooks with
over a hundred thousand titles in
fiction nonfiction and periodicals now
I'm heading out today on a road trip
across the US and I am taking with me
nate silver's book the signal and the
noise why so many predictions fail but
some don't now if you want to listen to
that along with me you can download it
for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium or you can
download any other book you like for
free for a trial offer for one month so
I want to thank audible.com for
supporting veritasium and I want to
thank you for watching